good evening everybody and welcome to
this District area planning committee
meeting held on Thursday the 22nd of
September 2022.
my name is councilor Kevin Lagan and I'm
the chairman of this committee and I'm
joined by councilor Bruce hubner who's
the vice chair
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present at the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of microphones therefore can
I ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished
please reference a page or a paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
paper and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible please
members as per the president of this
committee I will suspend rule 8-3 the
requirement to stand while speaking
thank you uh item agenda two apologies
for absence burner may I have any
apologies for absence please
Channel names civil
schemes swing and white thank you
gentlemen thanks very much burner thank
you
move to item three which is minutes of
the last meeting the these recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the 13th of July 2022 found on pages 7
to 10 are approved as a true and
accurate record I so move no Mr chairman
sorry okay yes
I'm pretty I'm I may be getting a bit
sort of dodgery but I'm pretty certain I
was at that meeting and I don't appear
to be on the list of attendees
uh and if I wasn't it's a bit
embarrassing as I've obviously claimed
for the trouble
also I might add that uh in the Preamble
to this uh this particular meeting the
committee clerk seemed to have created a
ghastly Chimera called councilor sjn
Morley ah
okay bernica we uh note those who make
the relevant changes
apologies for that Council Morgan thank
you for raising them any any other
points
chairman as well I can't see my name on
there and I was definitely here as well
okay we LED that to the uh the list
Council Durham thank you
okay any other points members
okay so can we agree those with those uh
amendments by ascent thank you members
move on to point four members to
disclose this is these Declarations of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
and non-registerable interests relating
to items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they must also
require to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting do we
have any declarations
Council Durham and
um thank you very much chairman um
chairman I have a number of
um
things to declare I am a member of Essex
County Council I therefore have an other
registrable interest but chairman and I
also chair ektu which is the Essex
County traveler unit on behalf of Essex
County Council and I'm the deputy
Cabinet member and our portfolio
includes the Essex County Council and
Gypsy and traveler sites across the
county
cancer done
cancer Fleming
thank you chav um a registerable
interest as a member of Essex County
Council who are statutory consultants
and I should also declare that I sit on
Act 2 for Essex County Council thank you
thank you
now the Declarations members
thank you very much indeed
okay so we'll move on to the
applications before us this is point
number five this is an application
reference
2200344 ful which is land on the south
side of Malden Road wooden Mortimer
Essex we do have some public
participation on this agenda item
which we have an objector and Mr Russell
forward and also uh Mr Brady
um my apologies can I just get the name
there
um
Mr Brady
Parish Council Mr Brady oh it's Council
yep members I um had some problems with
technical technical equipment today so
we didn't get the uh the full agenda so
uh apologies if it stumbles a little bit
on on these speakers so um we have
objective Mr Ford
um do we do the presentation
yep so what we do we move to do the
presentation first I think Anna
and the applicants here yeah I've
already said that thank you very much
Anna would you like to take us through
lovely thank you through your term and
um
so uh first of all I'd like to know that
since the publication of the members
update to additional objection letters
have been received as well as a letter
from nmp highlighting the concerns
previously raised by residents it is
noted that the additional letters do not
add any further material planning
considerations from those already being
discussed in the officer report
the site is located to the south of
Malden Road
here and it is occupied by a number of
buildings
as you can see here in the location plan
and and it is largely hot or faced so
this is the existing site plan
this is the proposal I've learned so the
development is part retrospective in
nature and it seeks permission for the
change of views of the land for the
stationing of two deepsea traveler pts
comprising one mobile home and one
touring Caravan a pair of heat with
Associated heart standing
these are the
um
Caravans these are the Turing Caravans
here and the area that is
has been and will be hot surfaced is
that area here
um this is the tree protection plan
and these are some photographs of the
site this is the access to the side on
top the existing structures on the side
and the
beginnings of hot surfacing the West
part of the
structures
view to the South the touring Caravans
that they are
um they've been stationed there
used to the east Southeast
and then some more photographs again
southeast of the side west and south
I'll bring back the
post plan so as the site is located
outside that the defined settlement
boundaries and it does not constitute an
expansion an expansion or or an
intensification of an existing Tipsy
traveler site the development was
assessed against the Criterion D of
policy height six which requires the
council to give regard to the
sustainability and stability of the site
in doing so consideration was given to
the nomadic lifestyle of gypsies and
travelers which varies from that of a
settled community
this involves the use of private
Vehicles irrespective of the location
and therefore the use of public
transport would not apply in a similar
way as that for occupiers of
conventional housing
officers have also taken into
consideration the proximity of the site
to the settlement and
um and the proximity to Malden which is
as the largest settlement of the
district contains a large amount of
facilities Services education and job
opportunities
furthermore given that that our present
the ldp does not have allocations for
deep sea and traveler sites it is
considered inevitable that size located
in the countryside to come forward and
be considered
also should be noted that the modern
District Tipsy and travelers
accommodation assessment
figures represent a minimum and rather
than a maximum provision
um in relation to the objection letters
received it is noted that the majority
of them relate to the decorum of the
current occupiers it should be noted
that the planning system can only take a
pragmatic approach when it comes to the
behavior or current or future occupiers
of a site and the behavior of a certain
occupier cannot dictate the decision
making of an application
it is also considered that part of the
reason for the complaint could be the
fact that the side has not been fully
functional as a Dipsy site
so having assessed The Proposal against
all material planning considerations it
is considered the proposed development
would be acceptable in principle it will
be uh it would it would have an
acceptable impact on the character and
appearance of the area and it would not
have an adverse impact on the amenity of
the existing residents or the future
occupants of the site
uh no objection has been raised by the
highway Authority in terms of Highway
Safety and
um it is considered that the development
will have an acceptable impact on
equality in trees
on that basis and in the absence of
demonstrable harm the proposal is
considered to comply with the relevant
policies of the ldp and therefore
officers recommend approval of the
application on the basis of the
conditions on pages 34-37 of the agenda
and also Financial contribution towards
the recreational impact of the
development on Essex Coast
thank you very much Anna we do have two
public participants this afternoon we
have an objective Mr Russell forward as
Mr Ford here in the chamber thank you Mr
Ford and we also have a parish council
representative Mr Brady so we'll move to
Mr Ford first please Mr Ford you have
two minutes public speaking obviously
there's a very small clock up there to
give you some support once that starts
please just take your time and speak for
your two minutes
okay when you're ready thank you thank
you chairman you might be forgiven for
believing that this officer report was
written in the post-truth era there are
errors of fact research absences and
explained dismissed the relevant
planning history hence conclusions that
are untenable in the recommendation that
should unequivocally have been to refuse
planning permission as an antidote to
the report in my written submissions I
have offered you five reasons of refusal
they are fact-based precise respectful
of the planning history and derived from
local plan policy hence completely
defensible
you are not in jeopardy in your Gypsy
site provision the situation is neutral
The Proposal conflicts with policy H6
the applicant normally resorts to a site
today recently extended in Woodford
green they are not local and they're not
in need the site access was a green
Verge and we're really going to walk
kids onto the a414 when all the hgv is
delivering to our shops and businesses
Rumble by an increasing number it's a
material intensification seven mature
trees Five Oaks are chopped down without
a license the evidence is there to
prosecute and replant pursue this with
the forestry commission you have the
tools the site was hard surfaced at
Ground Zero and we get offered a bird
box biodiversity Net game you must be
kidding
for the gypsies the noise from the a414
is too loud their own experts say so you
cannot soundproof a caravan and if you
could they move and they change it's
unenforceable the hard-working council
tax plane residents of wooden water have
to experience this at Close Quarters
enjoying incessant bonfires outdoor
cooking shouting swearing barking it's
visually ugly and its impact is
diabolical planning and environmental
health do meet and they deserve better I
strongly urge you to reverse this weak
officer recommendation to other refuse
Planning Commission for the five reasons
I've given you I will be your ally in
any appeal thank you very much indeed
thank you Mr Ford thank you
okay now call for Mr Brady
um pleased to come forward
they could just say microphone if that's
kind of thank you thank you
yep so basically Mr Brady when you're
ready there you have two minutes is that
all right good right uh obviously the
parish council are opposed to this for
specific reasons which we've shown you
however in due respect you you don't
live there you don't realize what the
road is like
if you look at that concerns that
residents have I think you would have a
different attitude towards that also I
note that 66 people have written into
that's 56 more than the crematorium
which is getting planning permission so
I ask you to note that
I think
you'll find that the voters of wooden
water and hazely feel that this is a
very emotive issue I always find the
people that uh write in on the tip of an
iceberg and the iceberg is there's a lot
of residents in our Parish that are very
very opposed to this
and I think I might just
a bet on that because I can't I'm not
going to keep on quoting and I haven't
been to I I can't say anymore because as
you appreciate it I haven't got my
council's permission to say it anymore
that's lovely thank you very much thank
you
thank you
turn to the yeah area
Mr Brady
thank you very much
well members we have a recommendation oh
sorry the applicants here I believe um
Can the African would you care to come
forward
thank you very much we again the same to
two minutes once you start talking that
the clock will start talking down thank
you thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak yeah I've been
traveling all my life
and I I don't know if you're aware of it
it's a very very hard life it's it's a
it's very hard to get education for my
kids at doctors for the kids the my
oldest two kids 17 and 18 years old
they're they're they can't read or write
that they've been trying to look for
jobs that they can't get employed
because they haven't had an education
and all all we're looking to do is is to
try and settle down and and have a place
to live so my kids can go to school and
we can have
I have showed a local doctor surgery so
we can have the kids and myself and my
auntie they looked after properly my
aunt has
has uh special needs she has a lot of
difficulties she needs doctors she can't
travel anymore they're getting too old
has just
I I just I'd like to have a
please and the the the
sorry no just take your time take time
then my kids are settled now they're in
school and the younger kids they're
coming along great and I just like to
say that thank you very much
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank you
okay members we can now we have a
recommendation recommendation the
recommendation is to approve subjective
conditions do I have a second bar
Thank You seconded by councilor Stevens
okay members are now open the the debate
um yeah two things please uh
5.4.1 in the report unless I misreading
this
it just doesn't make sense
that's my first point do you want my
second point or should we uh so you want
to go to that first point and then we'll
go through them one by one councilman
uh sorry [ __ ]
5.4.1 uh did I mean that
it's about the it's the near it's the
location
to the nearest property
uh perhaps it's not 5.4.1 it's about the
um location
impact yeah
the net 5.4.2
5.4.2
can you just read the first couple of
lines
yeah
you want me to read that the nearest
property to the application site would
be the Gypsy traveler's traveler site
more than 55 meters away from the
application site
I don't understand that
yeah please yep thank you thank you
chairman sorry to clarify
what I mean is that the Tipsy traveler
side would be located more than 55
meters away from the nearest property oh
yeah so the application side would be uh
more than 55 meters away from the from
the neighboring site
so there isn't an existing Gypsy
traveler site no apologies for the
thank you thank you chair can I carry on
yeah please cancel 7.2
uh highways
so the highway Authority I have no
objection subject conditions
um I'm surprised about the highway
response because there are already three
roads onto the main road there
and recently there was a very serious
accident
and there have been a number of
accidents there
has the highway Authority not thought
about undertaking a traffic impact
assessment bearing in mind that you'll
have vehicles slow-moving vehicles
coming onto that main road was there no
impact assessment
through terminal and an impact
assessment is not normally been done by
the highway authorities for the
applicant to submit one if if necessary
but I can confirm that
um the highway Authority did not raise
an objection in terms of Highway Safety
uh obviously they've suggested
conditions which we've imposed
okay thanks Jeff
thank you very much
um chairman as one of the ward members
for uh wood and Mortimer I feel obliged
to speak
um
chairman I I have great sympathy and and
I do feel for the officers who've had to
make probably one of the hardest
recommendations they found themselves
having to make
um for tonight
um
largely because this um this case and it
is a case a case that's been going on
for nine months um this Authority has
actually taken out a high court
injunction at Great expense to uh to
this Authority
um and I have to say a lot of the high
court judges rulings were ignored and as
Mr Ford has said there were tpos
tpos not uh he did too there was an
unauthorized development work
um but clearly the officers have looked
at the policies and applied them as they
believe they fit
chairman
in the time I've been a member of seldom
have I had a case that has provoked more
correspondence uh telephone calls some
very upsetting telephone calls from
local residents I have to say more than
once have I had phone calls from
residents literally in tears and and it
has been a very tough and there's been
literally and I'm not exaggerating to
say hundreds of emails about this
particular site
Gemini have no acts to grind with
Gypsies and travelers as you as I heard
in my declaration I'm a chairman of the
Essex County traveler unit and I look
after
um the eight Essex County Council Gypsy
and traveler sites around the county so
I have a good experience of the Gypsy
and traveler community
but chairman I think
we need to address one or two points the
photographs showed the entrance onto the
a414 as being a distinct entrance
however that entrance was only created
by the traffic and the lorries to and
from the site by the applicant prior to
that as you see Mr Ford's submission it
was just a grass bank so this access has
been created artificially without
permission
the access also exits onto the a414
there is currently a local highways
panel
application being progressed for a
Crossing there because of the speed of
traffic and children are finding it
almost impossible to cross the roads
when there are when they get on and off
the school bus so this is an extremely
dangerous access for both vehicles and
for pedestrians it simply isn't safe and
the locals highways panel is in the
final stages of getting a pedestrian
Refuge if that actually happens
so chairman I I honestly think that we
need to take a step back and analyze the
uh points that Mr Ford has made the
other point that was said that this
wouldn't have a detrimental impact on
the neighbors this site is enclosed
by neighbors all the way around the
rears of the neighbor's Gardens all back
onto this site
and although I appreciate the fact that
there is possibly an element of the fact
that the
um
the experiences that they've had over
the summer are maybe as a result of the
fact that this is an undeveloped site
but they have endured
nine months of very difficult situations
here because of the unauthorized work
that's gone on because of the
unauthorized inhabitant the the high
court judge made very particular rulings
and and I'm afraid I have to say that
these have not been followed
and chairman
this is a Greenfield site in a rural
Village it is not a suitable site for
any habitation not just specifically for
Gypsies and travelers but for any form
of development so chairman I I have
scraped sympathy as I said with the
officers I think the the other thing
that was mentioned was the fact that
um the occupant
will have the lifestyle of a traveler
and I'm fully aware of the lifestyle of
Travelers but it my information is
that the applicant actually leaves for
work and arrives back from work on a
daily basis at a regular time so clearly
he is occupying or he has employment in
the normal sense of the word so I don't
appreciate I do not believe that he
necessarily fulfills the criteria to be
a to be a traveler so chairman I
honestly think that there is sufficient
information
whether the officers agree with the very
comprehensive letter that Mr Ford has
sent out on behalf of the residents I
honestly think there is suitable
information in there
um and I think that that we owe it to
the residents of uh wooden Mortimer
to resist this application uh because it
simply does not fit where it is thank
you thank you councilor Dan
um just I'll just let the officer to
return and then I'll come around to the
councilor councilor Morgan's next
yes um to determine in in relation to
the access
um let me just bring up the plans
here
um obviously I don't have the photograph
that Mr Ford added into his letter but
even when you look at the Google Maps
you can clearly see that there was an
access there which was probably because
the site was not in use they've just put
a panel and it was overgrown it's that
doesn't mean that necessarily there
wasn't any access they haven't done
anything also they haven't done anything
to form a formal access per se
um but also the highway Authority has
recognized that they will utilize an
existing access onto Malden Road this is
in their letter
uh that in relation to access
just for a bit more clarity as you can
see on that photo there you can actually
see there is obvious and there was a
drop curb and I think it's actually even
clearer in Mr foe uh Mr Ford's photo he
says and obviously the applicant hasn't
done any Highway work so clearly the
fact there is a joke word drop curb
evidence is that historically there has
been an access that it's just obviously
it was overgrown as Tess chocolate said
wasn't being used but that's actually
very fundamentally different to
installing a new access and as Mr who
said the highway Authority have happily
acknowledged us historically been an
access there and obviously I think it'd
be very dangerous to go against what the
highway Authority is saying in respect
of that thank you
foreign
just said and the Egyptian traveler's uh
guidance from government does encourage
us to look at Brownfield sites first
before looking at Greenfield sites and
secondly or thirdly in relation to the
trees
um a number of trees were taken down the
council servatory preservation order on
the site my understanding well we've
received a number of complaints officers
have been down and we've found no
evidence of breach of that tree
preservation order since um it was
served for clarity I know we have been
have been allegations but officers of no
evidence
um and I think you just referenced Mr
folds uh opening Gambit
um where he stated
um in relation to the forestry
commission so I think he was
acknowledging that the trees that went
downward prior to the TPO not after the
TPO being certain I said we have been
down this enforcement and we've got no
evidence of any further work to
situation don't you
thank you you said yesterday just on
that last Point regarding trees
um
my information which is largely comes
from the residents when they used to
phone me on a Friday night or at the
weekend when they heard chainsaws
buzzing that is after the TPO
um and you know our members can decide
whether the weekend work was done
deliberately or not I I wouldn't like to
say but chairman I don't think there's
any doubt that there has been clearance
since the TPO and there has been
clearance since the injunction was taken
out and I'm absolutely certain you know
I I trust the
um the residents because they have taken
photographs from their bedroom windows
Etc
so chairman I I think I regret to say I
actually think that the we as an
authority we haven't visited the site to
the extent that we should have done
during this period
for clarity that is comparing
photographs that we've taken on the site
and we've not evidenced any different
it's not just about trying to catch
people into under action what I would
say in relation to
uh if there have been chainsaws and that
isn't obviously clearly evidence there's
a breach of a tea preservation or a
chainsaw that being used there were
Works to trees that resulted in Timber
being on site prior to the two
preservational being served Works to
remove those trees would not have
acquired consent under the TPO and
wouldn't have been stopped by an
injunction so chainsaws could have been
in Malaysia I don't like to make
assumptions or to guess but we're sort
of being dragged into that but what I
can say is officers have been down
they've reviewed photos that they took
at various stages and there was no
evidence that the counselors have
additional Works to trees being taken
thank you Chan thank you councilor
Morgan
no thank you chairman uh obviously I'm a
fellow World member with uh councilor
Durham for this uh for this area
um and fully support everything that he
says in in and urge you to do that it
would be simple to suggest that this is
some form of bigotry of
uh in the sense of uh sort of outrage
didn't be seeking to push away sort of
Travelers it would be simple but it
would be wrong that is exactly not as
precisely not what is happening here
um my brief association with the uh
certainly the parish council of wooden
water is that they have every sympathy
uh with
um the applicant and his aspirations and
where he wants to have a site but that
site is not here
um we've already discussed the access uh
we're just off of the a414 just before
the roundabout there that it is simply
uh on the look I simply cannot
understand why his Essex highways have
not brought this up but to access uh
that site off the road would would be
very dangerous
um also I would urge uh
um members if they think that this is
the sort of attitude that's happening to
put that out of their mind and to look
at the representations made by The
Carriage Council and in particular I'm
interested as to why there were two
previous applications around this site
one in 1917 and 1980s
2017-2018 uh one for uh the removal of
the hard standing and the construction
of two detached dwellings uh and then
another of the demolition existing in
the construction of two Chalet Bungalows
why they were refused and yet this
application has been uh allowed I don't
I simply don't understand the logic of
that but but before we go further
further on onto that one
um
the um
the planning policy for the
um
The Travelers sites 2015 specifically
states that local planning authorities
should very strictly limit new traveler
site development in open Countryside
that is away from settlements or outside
areas in the development plan and I
wonder how much uh uh notice the
officers have taken to that also there's
the variability or lack of alternative
accommodation for the applicants I
believe there are other sites available
that they could be used and I also then
go back to this question of are they
actually uh genuinely Travelers I
understand that it is perfectly possible
for me to state that I am now a woman to
use with female facilities uh clearly
that would be ridiculous in the same way
does it mean just by owning a caravan
does that make you a traveler I I
suggest not and I wonder how much
um sort of
Investigation officers have made into
the actual applicants of Bona fides on
that situation
thank you chairman so in in relation to
the previous applications that there
were refused obviously there is a clear
difference between
um Caravan sites Caravan pizza
and travelers pts and conventional
housing paragraph
5.3.13 of their report explains why the
previous applications were refused and
as I said in my presentation and as it
also has been stated within the report
there is a clear difference between the
um sustainability credentials that we
would expect and accessibility
um to facilities and services between
conventional housing and Gypsy and
traveler sites
and also consideration the inspector
dismissed
um those up the latest application on
impacts on the character of the area
it's different adding to domestic
properties onto a
um outside the settlement boundary
um from Caravans that they are mobile
and they actually do not need permission
as that they they do not constitute
operational development themselves
um and in relation to the noise this is
also clearly
uh explained within the officer's report
that the position of the house is was a
lot closer to the highway and that was
the main reason it was considered the
impact in terms of noise would be
unacceptable whilst here the Caravans
under this application would be located
further away from the road
um
I believe I've covered that in relation
to your point about the
um
about the uh
Caravans being located into the
countryside
uh actually legislation says the the the
contrary and this is also stated within
the
officer's report
it's the for you chairman not
specifically my Asian type point and the
government advice which councilman
referenced and as explained previously
this is a Brownfield site this is
previously developed land and the exact
same piece of guidance in paragraph 26a
of that guidance clearly explicitly
advises that we should be using
effectively used previously developed
brackets Brownfield land so that point
by Council Morgan is
incorrect I'm not saying that you know
that these hat members have to agree
that this is the most effective use of
previously developed land but the point
raised by Council Morgan in relation to
why we should resist it on that guidance
is flawed and it would actually
encourage the use of this land because
it is previously developed
thank you
thank you very much uh next I've gotten
this Council stamp
thank you chairman
um my questions if you're listening
officers is quite quite quick really I'm
sorry do you want to finish your
conversation over you okay thank you
um are there any other vacant sites um
that could they could be accommodated in
the district have we got any sites
nowhere
just bear with me bear with me and the
next one is can I actually see the
evidence about the ecology and the
biodiversity gain that we would you have
to balance yeah we're all being told we
have to balance Building Development
wherever in the district and I noticed
that the um the gentleman from Smart
planning turned around and said oh we're
getting these two back boxes I think
it's been requested on more than one
occasion that we had some sort of Matrix
to say what the the get the loss and the
Gain Is by having some sort of
development whether it be traveling
Egyptian Travelers or houses all right
shaking your head but
I I would like to see evidence because
it is a real real issue about us
building on Greenfield or Brownfield
sites or allowing things to happen which
may then develop what toilet blocks or
other facilities outside and I know Mr
Lee's going to turn around and say we
can't actually plan for that but it may
happen so yes have what's the game
against the loss you've already said
trees have been cut down so to me that's
the loss thank you thank you chairman
okay through your chairman
um about the uh about the first point
um where we both shook our hands we
don't have and I did say when I was
doing the presentation it's also within
the officers report we do not have
allocated sides within our ldp there
aren't any vacant sites that we are
aware of and we don't have any allocated
ones I think that's
so did we not allocate it in our ldp any
sites at the ldp yeah we did so we was
remiss then all those years ago we
didn't know any gyps and traveler sites
yeah that's correct and
um in relation to the ecology part there
isn't necessarily a matrix this is not
typical for
um any application for new housing or
Dipsy sites to submit a matrix with
benefits and harm the the supplication
was supported by preliminary ecological
appraisal which is typical when you have
um like either housing or for deep
Seaside or or actually when when it
could be a potential impact on on
ecology
and the ecological appraisal advice that
um there will be no further Works to the
trees and apart from the butt boxes and
bird boxes which is again very typical
as a biodiversity net gain to any
development that I mean even in our
major housing schemes that's basically
things that we ask in terms of
um equality enhancement
um the there was a provision of an
ecologist being on site if if any
further Works would be required to be
carried out within the site so that
covers that in relation to the trees I
believe
um my colleague Mr Lee have already
explained that this was prior to the um
tpos so that they could have removed
them
with no concerns did you come back on
that I'd like to come back so so in my
my simple mind we're actually starting a
minus position anyway so we've already
lost that but that by our diversity net
gang because we've already removed some
of the trees and that is what I tell you
every planning application at the moment
is coming to this Council we're having
trees taken down yeah and I think we
really do need to be conscious we've got
climate strategy we're supposed to be
looking after our environment and was to
me I could be wrong we're starting on a
negative but the offices don't need to
come back it was a point I was making
thank you very much councilor stem next
on the list is Council Fleming thank you
chair
um I have concerns about the suitability
of this site to be honest
um I mean that's because I I drive this
road four times a day it also features
in my inbox as a division member
probably have two or three emails a week
about speed weight of traffic Highway
Safety
um I mean so my concerns around the
access that access and Highway Safety
the road is a 50 mile an hour limit but
cars travel much faster than that uh
it's an accident black spot I know the
highways Authority uh gave you know
their response to consultation and said
it was acceptable but I'm wondering
whether that was actually bearing in
mind that at the Northwest committee uh
in August gave permission for Claremont
Garden Center a new restaurant and Cafe
there so that actually does alter the
situation where with highways on the
ground it will do when that's enacted
they gave permission
um so that will make the situation worse
so my question to the officers is you
know has that been factored in thank you
thank you councilor Fleming for your
chairman no that wouldn't have been
factored in but what I would suggest is
that when you extract like that over the
full week and things that application
would have a very limited impact in
relation to uh highways thank you
okay
do they come back cancel the Fleming yes
thank you chair
um also I mean I have concerns about the
suitability of the site because there
are no shops similar to Mortimer
um there are no facilities and there's
no it's a grass Verge you can't walk
from the site we're supposed to be
promoting sustainability you know
there's no foot way there that for me
that's why it's an unsuitable site thank
you
Nick Cassler keys please thank you I
think John
um what historically what was this site
they said it was a Brownfield and I'm
just I see this historic Concrete in
there do we know what it was used before
because I had a site in my ward which we
got an application for that there was an
argument that it could have been a farm
and they said well if it was a farm it
can't be because 90 of the farms in the
UK are on economical I just wondered if
it was was this farm buildings or was
this it was farm buildings
through your tournament yes he he does
include Stables which is not farm
buildings but also some um
um
it was agriculture it wasn't everything
users are not agriculture yeah I know
the side but I I was on young I didn't
know how long it was it's been
historically
um uh they were saying also when we go
to The Travelers pitch in my Awards in
in captionswood road we granted off the
top of my head I believe it's four or
six now when I drove by there the other
day there was no Caravans in there so
are they occupied or are these granted
and they're not being used do we know on
that or just it's just a comment you
know
I don't have that information I'm afraid
okay
all right no Future No thank councilor
Keys uh next stuff I've got members
we've got quite a list of people but
because of the the detail that we need
to debate I think we should go through
and give everybody ample opportunity
um count suspensely next please
thank you chair
um so I've come to this report with a
completely open mind okay that's that
would always be my position
and I really do understand that the
officers have had a tremendously
difficult job in writing this however I
don't know anything about this
application previously I've not been
involved in it in any way and just
speaking from the heart from a really
honest point of view we get to 3.2.1 on
the conclusion and it's heartbreaking
how can we say and I know councilor
stamp has already started to you know
have made this point but just reading
this again in the absence of any
demonstrable harm and the words that
subject to conditions that will have a
bad uh be able to achieve a biodiversity
gain I think we have a responsibility to
our residents not to be so fanciful
we're not even being honest with
ourselves in a meeting here um just a
few weeks ago I was told that we've got
nobody to actually monitor the
enforcement of ecological conditions how
can we say when we've got trees here
that would have been hundreds of years
old that were going to put up a few bat
boxes and a few bird boxes and it'll all
be okay it won't and if we're serious
about climate action this is an issue
completely apart from all the rest of it
we can't keep writing reports where
we're talking about biodiversity net
gain and it's not real it makes no sense
to us it makes no sense to the residents
and I really do think we need to find a
way of being honest about biodiversity
gain or loss because at the moment we're
not fooling anybody and I do also I do
take a little bit of exception to they
could have come along and cut down those
trees anyway now I I would question that
that if you've got mature oak trees that
we're saying that if you come along and
you cut them all down and then you put
in a planning application it'll be fine
that's what it sounds like correct me if
I'm wrong
chm just for that point that is a major
flow in the planning system but yeah
that legally is true
um the trees aren't protected and they
can be cut down and then you're able to
submit an application that's yeah I
think well that if that's the case
that's very sad but I don't think we
need to I don't think we need to sit
here in a report and be fanciful and say
that it's a biodiversity Net game
because it absolutely isn't thank you
suspensely
yeah thank you chairman sorry I just
want to add a little bit more on net
biodiversity conditions 14 and 15 of the
officer report do state that
um the development should be implemented
in accordance with a preliminary
ecological mitigation a colonial scale
appraisal mitigation enhancement
measures and that would include two bad
boxes and two bit boxes planting of
native species of trees shrubs and
hedges
uh condition 15 relates to external
lighting there was no proposal for
external lighting but if in the future
they wanted to add an external Lighting
in order to protect uh species we would
expect details of that to be submitted
and approved in writing also as part of
the application we have imposed a
landscaping condition that would require
require them to submit details of soft
landscaping and also although it has not
been shown on the plan
uh here we are the three consultant has
advised that these three could be
retained and this is secured by
condition so these three that was
recommended for removal we have a
condition to keep that trade I think
yeah thank you
um next on my list I've got councilor
Morley please
thank you chairman
um my concern is the environment agency
have they visited this site
the burning of waste and sorting of
waste do they have a license to carry
out here is that um
probably another planning issue I expect
but
how's that being handled at the moment I
haven't seen anything in here at the
moment
there's a condition is there
it's a bit of both there is a
conditioning relation specifically but
the wider picture wouldn't be a planning
issue per se generally unless the
burning of waste and we've put a
condition would require that there is no
burning of waste right but you know
there is an Evidence of software acting
as a weight transfer station or anything
like that no thank you they'll be
monitored that'll be checked
no good chairman as always we do not
have resources to proactively uh check
any conditions
yeah we will We best get obviously if it
may be something a different Authority
would receive a complaint about and they
would deal with it under their powers
thanks okay thank you I've got councilor
Hamilton councilor Stevens so councilor
Helm please
thank you Mr chairman um can you tell me
whether the land is wholly owned by the
applicant
for start
through tournament as far as I'm aware
no it's not
has he written to other people who own
the land to tell them what he's doing
this is what the applications you're
meant to do you're meant to inform them
in writing what you intend to do because
I've had it done to myself someone
applied for plan information on my
allowed I'm there to write to me and
tell them and you have to have a
certificate for that have you had that
yeah the application form within their
application from the scientists yes well
how come I've got an email with a
paraphus the owner of the other bit of
land is passport information and he says
he hasn't got permission and he's not
going to sell any bit or let anything
for anything else
the chair I'm in relation to that and as
all members have probably heard me say
before the ownership of an application
is an a material consideration the
applicant has stated his scientific
certificate uh bay we have to take that
in good faith as always the I've seen
been a whale survey email for someone
saying they have in the land and they're
not looking to sell the land of and as
members know though the fact that
someone has stated that is not Material
consideration termination education
ownership per se is number two
consideration
um yeah whether or not the app there is
an owner except for owner that person
has written to us so they haven't been
prejudiced if they have not been
consoled because that's what it would
come down to in the eyes of law has
someone been prejudiced the same fact
they've been able to write to us
highlighting the fact that they feel
that would mean that they haven't been
prejudiced per se so I don't think that
would be a consideration for any either
part why in terminations application
I'll come back with a bit more forecast
um yes that's correct but you can't
impose conditions on somebody else's
land can you
for your chairman you can set you can
impose conditions on a planning
application site irrespective of the
landowneries it would mean that it could
potentially mean well when I had this
happen to me
they couldn't do it the solicitor row
into the council so you can't impose any
conditions
because they don't own the land
for your chairman
um there is you can in postage they
might not be able to deliver it would
then mean they wouldn't be able to
deliver the application which could
result in an enforcement case but you
can impose conditions on the application
so I respect of who the landowner is
because planning permission sits on the
land not with an individual thank you
chairman thank you and more final if I
may you certainly may cancel the help if
you look at the entrance
there's all muddle over the road is that
continue going to be like that and cause
accidents when winter comes
well see the muddle down the side of the
road or on the edge all on the verge
there's the correct entrance is it
thank you determine highways have
suggested a condition for Unbound
materials to
um not go on the on the highway for a
highway safety and that's been
um
imposed
thank you thank you um next cancer
Stevens please
thank you chair can I just ask a
question first of all and then I'd like
to make some statements
um we heard
um councilor Durham I think said that
the applicant isn't traveling anymore
and I didn't quite catch what what you
said in your answer does that matter if
somebody's part of the traveling
Community isn't that the point
chairman uh Cat Stevens to reason you
didn't catch it was because I actually
forgot to comment on that point so thank
you for uh I knew there was something
I'd forgotten and that was the point
um the applicant has stayed with an
application now a part of the traveling
Community
um
there is a certain level of faith that
we have to take in relation to things
Council Morgan's Point about
um investigating it we are not allowed
to investigate it basically
um that there's caselo on that you know
that would be um I know it's difficult
in that respect
um but obviously just because your pilot
traveling Community doesn't mean that
you would be able to work locally at
certain periods and that changes through
the year
um so
there's that point but secondly because
we're suggesting a condition that would
say that the occupied would have to be
part of the traveling Community if
the individual that moves on this is for
any Gypsy travel site when you put this
condition on it could be that they start
off as a Travelers and coming under the
definition in future because they decide
to settle because they even difficulties
even actually in theory even if they
retire it can cause problems for them
and that they then no longer fall into
that definition if they would be a
breach of planning control but that
would be something for the future but
our information is that they are within
they do fall within the definition and I
think it'd be dangerous to challenge
that any further thank you chairman
thank you thank you okay so um
but it's it's irrelevant in other words
whether somebody is actually traveling
up down the country at the moment or
they're part of that community and at
the moment they're here
the chairman what I would say to
something that you've um
you've made a fairly valid point is that
this application is not
um a personal commission it is an
application for Gypsy and travelers site
it
um the applicant has not put forward
um any extensive personal circumstances
um they've obviously made certain
comments as they did in their two
minutes and I think that's fairly
standard it's fairly not surprising
um the government clients is clear that
we shouldn't only be looking to meet the
demands of Travelers within this
District it's and just as just because
there's no local connection we can't
resist it for that reason
um
the number of the sites that we have
granted more recently over my time at
Malden either have had personal
commissions or had slightly restrictions
to allow people outside Travelers and
this isn't that this is an application
just for a solely for this site and
there is no material considerations that
the officers are putting forward and I
would say that what the applicants
performed is two minutes don't fall
under very special circumstances I'd
advise members to not give that any more
weight than
maybe the reason why Lady every traveler
might want their own site
um and that yeah it is an application
just purely for a traveler's site and
the personal circumstances or the
applicant to sense in other move point
in the termination of this specific
application thank you
okay thank you very much
so I haven't heard any reasons tonight
why this should be refused I've heard a
lot of opinions and some quite
ugly opinions I've heard a lot of things
that haven't got anything to do with
this application whether we would like
them to be or not I don't like trees
being cut down but that doesn't relate
to this application
um
the Essex highways have not said this
can't go ahead we object we might like
them to have done but they haven't
um chainsaws at the weekend well you
know that's sort of living in a
neighborhood isn't it there's always
somebody doing some project or something
at the weekend there's always some dog
or a chainsaw or children running about
shouting that's just living in a
neighborhood there's always a bit of
noise I think you need to live in the
middle of nowhere if you can't accept
that and we need to make a lawful
decision tonight we can't go into this
and say well I'd like it to be like this
and so that's the way I'm voting I think
we've really got to examine ourselves
carefully and make sure we make a lawful
decision tonight please members thank
you thank you I think that's the reason
why we're here and I think members will
make it through an informed debate and
vote accordingly thank you for the
statement and thank you for the
contribution accounts the stilts please
5.8.3 talks about the summary of
appropriate assessment and it says it
concludes that the project will without
mitigation have a likely significant
effect on sensitive interest features of
European designated sites due to scale
and location of the development proposed
then we set a figure
where have we got that figure from
determine yes this is a figure that's
been given from uh Natural England in
two two two
three chairman the figure is based on
our s adopted SP day that is Essex wide
that is aimed at me in the uh offset in
the harm from
new residential accommodation on the uh
designated sites this paragraph and
section has been in every committee
report to do with the new dwelling of
personal sex uh new housing whether it's
a thousand houses or one house for the
last three four years so and that's just
the approach that the council takes and
whole of Essex takes in relation to
meeting the harm by additional dwellings
on the
um protected sites thank you chairman
yeah I'm just going to come back Council
still thank you for that explanation but
where do we get that figure what what
says to us that that piece of land is
only worth 137 pounds 71 per dwelling
for you chairman um what how that figure
is calculated is that Essex made a
decision on a range of and a suite of
activities that they were going to bring
forward to look to mitigate harm That
Was Then divided by the expected number
of dwellings across S6 within those
areas and it worked out at
um it was actually slightly lower than
that at the time because it's index
linked
um per dwelling and that is one dwelling
is that figure and that's the same for
the whole of Essex thank you chairman
thank you because um let's talk about
Council fluka and then about councilor
Darren
yeah thank you chairman I mean
I I think this debate and this planning
application must be of great interest to
the Gypsy Council of this country
because you know I think what we're
basically saying here is is that you
know we
we're not up to speed with our travel
sites
um which opens the doors for these type
of applications and and
you know it's a bit like the way these
policies are if I was to go and buy a
Wurlitzer based on what you've just said
and I I wrote you and said I'm now a
showman yeah I could then buy a piece of
land in Thomson's nights and then apply
for my Gypsy Caravan so and and I you
know I'm afraid members is
people have spoken against this
application but no one's come forward
the best we've got now and the best
we've got in the moment and I can see
the minutes councilor Durham says
um based on what the objectors agents
sent we should oppose it or refuse it
but you know I'd like to hear what the
members are actually saying about
policies and why they think it's not
policy compliant so that we can actually
extend the debate in the right direction
because you can discount highways you
know we can't you know if we were to go
to appeal
highways would become uh you know a
conflicted
contributor to the appeal so we can't do
that you know I mean I often wonder
sometimes with the county members who
sit on this committee
um while they don't engage with their
own highways Authority and perhaps be at
be absolutely clear with them what these
situations are I mean I know the
location and I go past it you know I've
been past it today to us but
unfortunately Highway saves acceptable
and we can't argue that so chairman I I
hope that soon and I know councilor
Dunham's speaking next he's going to
come up with some reasons perhaps why he
thinks this committee should refuse this
application policy reasons and Council
fluka cassador
thank you I'm going to disappoint
Council of Luca
um I just want to point out where where
there are some
um understandable mistakes from what the
officer has said to us in relation to
councilor stance question
um
members that have been here sometime
might remember our first try at getting
our ldp adopted and that was actually
kicked back by the inspector on the
basis of he was not satisfied with our
Gypsy and traveler allocation so we have
addressed our Gypsy and traveler
allocation and fortuitously at that time
the government reclassified what it
calls a traveler and a traveler can't be
classed as a traveler unless they travel
that is so that actually reduced the
number of gypsy and traveler sites that
this Authority had to provide and this
Authority has a supply of gypsy and
traveler sites this Authority has a
Netflix County Council traveler's site
permanent site not two miles from this
application site in in wooden water I
don't know whether there's any free
space on it but that is a legitimate
Gypsy and traveler site
um and by the applicant I have great
sympathy with the applicant but by his
own admission he wants to settle down
and and not travel and because of an
aging uh an infirm relative so they do
not fulfill
the classification that we got our ldp
adopted on the back of that they are
legitimately traveled
another case when councilor Morgan asked
why the this was different to the
previously refused schemes and the
officer said were they were for houses
I just might draw attention to the fact
that what we're actually looking at are
although legally the the buildings are
being applied for are Caravans they're
effectively single story Lodge houses
they are not the typical white metal
Towing Caravans touring Caravans there
are two single story
dwellings in effect like Bungalows so
you know there is yes I accept the fact
that in legal terms that is a caravan
but you can't just hitch them up and
pull them out and or move them
um
trust me I've tried so
um chairman you know really we we have
enough grounds to find ishore to take
issue with the officer's recommendations
the most glaringly obvious and I'm
sitting here looking at a Google Earth
photograph of that site
and I've known that site for 40 years
probably probably more
and it was a disuse stable if you like
that ramshackle old buildings but it was
effectively wild heavily vegetated large
trees it was effectively a wild site and
you can see it similar by the site as
you drive past it the site adjacent it
has been cleared there's no there's no
other definition it has been cleared and
you can see from from the pictures up
there so
how are we going to get an ecology net
gain it's just it's it's nonsensical
because any ecology and it was a green
wild sight with all of the animals and
the insects and everything that live and
occupy that site have gone never to
return
so to say an absolutely sit here and say
there will be an ecology net gain is
crass beyond words because it plainly is
not the case and it will never get to
the position that it was before
so I'm sorry there is suitable uh to to
please councilor fluka there are
suitable policy reasons and that one of
the reasons that you've given for
approval is that there'll be an ecology
net gain not true thank you
Council Durham um I think we've we've
you know if there's any members I've got
um councilor Thompson and then if
there's any member who hasn't spoken um
and they wish to speak then I'll give
time for those but then after councilor
Thompson I'd like to go to the
recommendation and go to The Vow members
please Council Thompson
thank you chairman can I start with a
quick reference to council Fluker and
his um fugitive Wurlitzer I mean he's
absolutely right there is
um a Showman's traveling showman site in
my Village that's why we picked
Donaldson Knights and the appeal
inspector in that case did not impose a
condition chose make appointment not
imposing a condition that any occupants
be members of the Showman's Guild which
is the normally accepted qualification
as a showman so in fact he's absolutely
right you better go hunting on eBay
Council fluka because you could indeed
move in and Lauren D was there any
requirement for any of those showman
actually to travel or before dinner
Showman's business but anyway that's by
the buy my question please for the
officers through you chairman is
when you look at biodiversity again
I'm kind of assuming that you can only
look at the situation at the point the
planning application is put in and
rather than what used to be there before
um
on the supposition that anyone can buy a
piece of land and clear it with no
intention of putting any planning
application in for anything
um would I be right if I could hear from
the office was really I'd be grateful
please yeah can you say one yeah that's
that's correct it's taken from the point
of the of the application
and and also the side could have been
brought back into its previous years and
that could have had an impact to
yeah to the to the wildlife there okay
thank you very much indeed members well
I think we've actually got a
recommendation to approve which is uh
seconded by councilor Stevens
um so I want to do this by a show of
hands or does anybody want to record a
vote
yeah
is that seconded
thank you Council so the recorded vote
called by Council Stevens and seconded
by councilor Shaughnessy
are you there burner
sorry
uh can you please stay clearly four
against the current state and this is
for the office recommendation about
against
the jewick the games
counselor Darren
against
cancer Edwards okay
against
I've got to abstain because I don't know
what grounds we're
voting against officer's recommendation
apart from ecology well we'll do that
yeah stay in Council of Lucas gonna be
staying
thank you
against
foreign
[Music]
against
[Music]
abstain
for
eign
against
um
against
Stein
four
Epstein
abstain
s
four
that's the stilts abstain
foreign
ER thank you
so that's four for the recommendation
nine against eight abstentions Penny
challenge
so we need some reasons
okay okay
so members that the the recommendation
approve has failed so um we need some
grounds for refusal
or
no grounds
No One's Gonna Move anything then well
chairman I mean I can start with um
unacceptable detrimental impact on the
um rural amenity and the immunity of
Neighbors
yeah
dear chairman um
for clarity when you say we're all means
you talk about character or just the
impact on the neighbors both Jim okay
obviously um just sentence the first
point once don't say subjective
obviously government advice does
encourage them on Brownfield sites which
this is
um the site is heavily screened by the
retained structure so I would have some
concerns in relation to that in relation
to impact on the neighbors
um I know there's been a lot of public
uh objections to it but I think you need
to have two things in mind with this
members firstly is that and as
cheshugler explained earlier the
planning system needs has to take a
reasonable approach to the decorum of
occupiers so the fact that a certain
individual May create noise or
disturbance above and outside of what a
regional person the Bell diagram might
do isn't a reason for fuse automatically
um and that matters for environment
protection to deal with which is
separate to the planning system and the
second point is that obviously I think a
number of the issues that have been
raised partly would have been by the
injunction we've served see stopping
them from being able to connect to the
services so it's potential that some of
the noise disturbance issues that have
been raised wouldn't actually fall away
as planned from issues granted so I
would have come some concerns in
relation to that point as well members
thank you chairman I'll stand by those
reasons thank you thank you Council
Darren the council do it
thank you chairman
um I mean I would have thought it's the
one catch-all that we'd normally do with
any development outside of a village
that is used all the time and that is
that the site is unsustainable
thank you
the channel I would say is as much
you've said a couple of times now and
the office report says and the
government guidance is clear on the
sustainability test for Egyptian
traveler site is very different and I
would think that would be very difficult
to defend an appeal thank you chairman
you have to accept
Okay Okay so we've actually got um a
recommendation for the refuels with some
points from councilor Durham
um Berna did you capture I got Council
of Durham at the table
but it's not
um
food chairman I think it's was it for my
understanding is that it's uh impact on
the character in the area from the
proposed developments one reason for
view so and the second one would relate
to impact on the amenity of the
neighbors uh the only thing I would
request is if cancer Darwin could expand
a little bit because obviously impact on
the mean it could be noise disturbance
overlooking overshadowing Etc just for a
little bit of clarity would would be
helpful to the officers and I'm sure to
the members when voting thank you
chairman
thank you thank you Mr Lee
um
chairman
the neighbors will now have a
development of clearly on view from
their rear garden and from all of their
houses if that isn't a detrimental
visual impact I don't know what is and
I'm getting a little bit
miffed to be quite honest and I do have
sympathy with the officers
but there has been plenty of information
provided about reasons for potential
reasons for refusal and and I would
expect those to be tested
um so chairman I I stand by this and I
honestly think that you know it has been
harmful environmentally
ecological has been harmed I do not
believe that we can stand by and
substantiate an ecology net gain
chairman now you know we can go on
forever and ever come this can't we
um
but you know on the basis that there are
so many
local complaints
and the fact that this Authority has
spent literally tens of thousands of
pounds in a high court
I would expect a planning inspector
should it come to that to at least take
due regard whether he applies those uh
in his decision making or not but I
think it's absolutely relevant in this
case thank you thank you councilor any
comments so
um
would that would Council Durham's
reasons to recommend that for a refusal
stand would they be valid three Cham for
clarity we asked for expansion on impact
on the neighbors obviously cancer Dam
did they talked about Outlook um which
obviously I would just highlight the
recent costs appeal in Stony Hills when
we try to defend us
um and actually also in um Tinkers hold
too as it's colloquially known when we
tried to defend those sort of out
arguments and inspectors both found them
to be significantly flawed um but in
relation to a college I'm not sure if
he's looking to progress a third reason
for refusal or not yeah just just um if
I could just pull the meeting back
because my role as chairman is to cheer
the meeting and I think um that the
cassadorum would welcome support
um and yes we've as a local Authority
we've had previous
um failures in the system but I think
we're looking at this as you know and
you've taught us we're looking at this
application in its on its own so if
there's help and support and there's
valid reasons why uh councilor Durham
has tabled and you can help maybe
perform the words afterwards if it's
legal and it's valid and it's a member's
wishes then we should look at performing
that word if it's a valid reason
um or if Council Durham is to
extrapolate a little chairman and I'll
also add that we we do not have um a
you know we we do have a satisfied Gypsy
and traveler allocation at the moment it
hasn't been proved otherwise and we have
a a formal Gypsy and traveler site
within two miles of this particular site
just refer to the officers
absolutely
I'm getting a little bit confused so
you've you've said that one reason was
the Inbox and the carricks of the area
then you've said another reason is the
impacts are neighbors and I believe you
referred to Outlook just to reiterate
the nearest property it's 55 meters away
and um I believe you then pointed you've
said you've made reference to another
reason for refusal about ecology and now
do you also add to the reasons for
refusal the not identified need for a
deep suit site I would be really worried
if we do that because it's not it's not
a ceiling what is within the with the
ldp it's it's it's the minimum it's
similar to housing it's not a ceiling
but yeah
free for clarity members there actually
is a five year land Supply test for
Gypsy and traveler sites it's exactly
the same as Miss tashjaku said it's not
a it's not seeming it is a floor and the
policy allows for additional sites so I
would be concerned that that as a
principal reason for Fusion thank you
thank you
question yes I'd ask if the officers has
the ecology and the biodiversity game
been tested anywhere because it it's
at Appeals
foreign
I'd have a
I think it'd be a dangerous approach to
take that if a consultation says some
things Etc and we just say well we've
not tested a pill we should ignore that
would be a very dangerous approach
generally not saying about specific but
that's so what I feel like you've just
said is like so we haven't tested it at
appeal because we'd be testing whether
we disagree with one of our
consultation's responses as a starting
point so that would be something the
local planning Authority would not look
to do Mr Lee's gone above and beyond I
didn't actually ask that I just wanted
to know whether whether we agree with
the tech Council console t or not it's
members decision to refuse this whether
it goes to I wanted to know if it has
been tested and what the possible
outcome of that would be but I thank you
for your information but you have gone a
bit too far for what I actually asked
um so has it been tested or not whether
whether the consultee has agreed or not
I don't I'm not bothered I want to know
has it been tested in the court
your question
okay let's cancel do it Mr chairman I'm
getting a little bit concerned about the
way this is going at the moment to be
honest I don't normally want to pick a
fight with the officers but their job at
this stage should be to try and help
members to come up with reasons for
refusal not to shoot everything down in
flames as soon as it's suggested but I
think we ought to put that in mind and
carry on with that before this goes any
further yeah thank you councilor Derek
I'll just let the officers come back
just quickly chairman
um and counts to its Point uh councilor
daramouse brought two foot forward at
the first point
um which I extrapolate that into two
from one ask Clarity I provided feedback
for the second Point obviously certain
impact on neighbors is a very broad
topic so office assault some clarity
on that matter that was all we asked for
and it appears that more items are being
brought forward but it as the
requirement of our practice is that it
is my responsibility as the gravity test
file here is to protect the council and
provide feedback on the validity of
reasons refusal I'm not here to pick
arguments with members but I am here to
give professional advice on the validity
of reads refusal sometimes
members might not like what I have to
say and you know and hopefully outside
the chamber we'll forget about that but
that's the reality of this
um and I apologize if you feel I'm
trying to shoot down but there are
points that we have raised and been
consistently through the meeting and we
can't then go against that professional
advice just because members don't agree
with it I'm afraid thank you chairman
but members um from my understanding
members have obviously it was almost as
a valid reason which councilor Durham
has brought a valid reason that or maybe
a couple of valid reasons we should take
that I think it's time now if that if
that's um seconded
yeah certainly Council down last time
yeah yeah I appreciate that I'm trying
I'm trying to help I'm trying to help
members and the awesome
I could produce 30 or 40 emails letters
accounts of how this site has impacted
on the residence immunity and they would
of course be taken into account by an
inspector okay
chairman so that's it
yeah is this I've seen that letters as
well you know but it's Council down
amazing issues in noise disturbance
that's all we want is Clarity because
amenity is such a bull topic
um it's a very dangerous approach to
have such an open and unspecific phrase
if you have examples of my advice would
be as always including
Etc like you would see in any reason for
fusible forward to the committee by
officers and that's all I would like
some clarity on the points for officers
if this application is refused and for
members when voting that if it ends up
an appeal we're able to drill into the
points of concern that the committee
have and not left to such a broad
undefendable position that's the only
Clarity I want and that is me trying to
assist members by asking this it's not
trying to be problematic
you haven't spoken so we'll just take
out the herd thank you chairman am I
writings uh my my concerns is the actual
access is coming straight off the field
into a site now because highways have
raised no objection we we can't use that
is that what you're saying
for you chairman yeah that is my advice
is that if the statue consult here is
saying this is acceptable we'd be very
dangerous approach for us to go against
that without some form of evidence
thank you thank you thank you finally
count suspensely before we just get
clarity it's just a point of clarity
that was all um so at 3.7
5.7.3 the application is supported by
the preliminary a preliminary ecological
appraisal was that our consultation then
all the applicants
yeah through your tournament the
applicant submitted the preliminary
operator appraisal and it's been
assessed by our ecology consultant okay
thanks very much it has it so it's our
our okay okay thank you
yeah thanks counselor said Thank You
officers so just to be clear
um
uh councilor Durham do you just want to
repeat
um your reason so that burner can
capture those in in completeness
um we can just make sure that we've got
what we need and then we can ask for a
second for that and then we can go to
the Vogue or not
I just want to be clear members because
it's uh
impact on the rural
nature of this particular site and it
will have a detrimental impact on
humanity and adjacent weddings thank you
whether you like it or not
can you accept
okay
I'm asking your professional devices
um I mean it is an acceptable reason for
refusal but I would need and everybody
would need some clarity whoever is going
to be defending this on appeal is that
when it comes to impact on a minute to
your neighbors there are several ways
that a development could have an impact
on neighbors that would include impact
on in terms of noise being overbearing
over shadowing resulting in loss of
light and impact on their their Outlook
but we would need to know whether we
need to fight all of them or you have
some specific ones that you you would
want
field
that will no longer be the case I think
I think members because I don't I don't
want to prolong any debates getting
quite members please
thank you
um I think what we've on previous
occasion Mr Lee we've had where we've
had a a form of words from uh from a
member which has been seconded and we've
also asked for officers help to
fine-tune those words after that could
we can we still do that through your
chairman obviously they won't be filming
the exact uh wording of the reasons for
you so as always and you know within the
wiggle room to uh
plan our eyes then we do that as always
but then obviously that's Miss Chess
chocolate was just looking for Clarity
on the immunity point and we'll be able
to extrapolate what countstone said into
that reason for diffuser thank you very
much chairman I'm very happy to rely on
Mr Lee's expertise and his long uh
knowledge and history of this particular
site to come up with a substantial
reason thank you councilor I am going to
let Council Morgan speak very quickly
before we as this was there a second of
accounts
well we'll come back we'll just do
counselor Morgan and then I'll ask for a
second uh yeah I just want to help
officers out yeah and just suggest that
since there were two applications for
houses on this site that were then
turned down and on the appearance of a
caravan they have bent over backwards to
actually pass it that perhaps they want
to look at the reasons for for rejecting
those previous applications might give
them an opportunity as a reason as to
rejecting this one members okay um we
need as a burner can we just read out
councilor Durham's um reasons for
refusal please just so we've clear
commented on the um adverse impact on
the amenity of the local of the local
residents and also mentioned uh the
impact on the character and appearance
of the area but there are as rather
details that we went through with the
officers yeah excellent members you all
understand that it's come through yeah
yeah anybody who's to second the motion
Mr chairman I say I'll second it quite
happily but I would like my
unsustainable reason included I think
that's a decision that obviously
officers and members are not necessarily
going to come to agree on but I think it
is something that should be considered
whether or not there are different
um levels of unsustainability for
travelers as against
permanent residences
Morgan actually put his hand up to
second that before you spoke so we would
have to are you happy to amend that
councilor Morgan Habit to amend that did
you capture that antara
Berna sorry yes I did Chairman thank you
very much I'm glad you did okay members
I think we've had a very um informed
very passionate debate based on facts I
would like to go to the vote now for
councilman Durham's
um reasons for for refusal
um do you want to do this by a cent or
would you like a recorded vote a
sentence for some members can I call for
Council Durham's reason for
recommendation by sent by show of hands
please
so that's one two three four five six
seven eight
nine do you agree with that nine so
that's nine for against and anybody uh
against the recommendations for refusal
so it's two again two three three four
five five six six seven against the yeah
so we're going against yeah
one two three
yes I've got three abstentions
yep so three people are staying seven
against a nine four councilor Darren's a
reason for refuel refusal so that
motions carried
okay members thank you very much indeed
for that debate
we now move on to uh agenda item six
okay members agenda item six is
reference number two two zero zero four
five four slash full linebrook Park East
Land South of wig Hill and line book way
more than Essex which is found on the
report pages 39 to 74. uh this report is
going to be provided by Miss Matthews I
believe
foreign
this area
you really miss Matthews
okay members um Miss Matthews to present
please
and members of the public my apologies
thank you chairman evening members
um
so this is
um an application for 42 dwellings on
part of the South Malden Garden suburb
and together with Associated
infrastructure
so this slide shows the location of the
application site and you have
um way along here and family road down
here and this site is partly under
construction by uh Taylor wimpy
foreign
so this is um a bigger site bigger plan
showing the the blue line is the Eastern
parcel
um and that the red line outlines the
application site
um which is
um subject to the application
and so the site for forms 1.4 hectares
um a part of the Strategic site s2a in
the LBP which gained outline plan
permission in 2016 for up to a thousand
dwellings along with the employment area
local Center Primary School
um child care facilities and social
infrastructure
um so the current proposal for 42
dwellings would be in addition to the
Thousand already permitted the site the
uh and the site the subject of the
outline plan permission was subsequently
separated into East and Western parcel
so the current application relates to
the Eastern parcel Reserve matters for
the residential elements of the Eastern
parcel totaling 606 dwellings and
infrastructure have been approved and um
construction has commenced
yeah
so this was just an extra the policies
map to show
where I was talking about
um so this is s2a which is the allocated
site I just mentioned and this is the
Eastern parcel where the application
site is located
so this is a um a plan of the Eastern
parcel as as approved so we've got phase
one here which is under construction
you've got phase two here and
um this is the application site here in
the middle you've got the football
pictures down on the southern boundary
and this area here is where the local
Center is going to go with the school
and the allotments
and then as a point this is where the
photos you'll see later on were taken
from just
um to locate them
this is a proposed layout
um and the asterisk red asterisk
dwellings are the affordable dwellings
so the the training will be a mix of um
semi-detached and detached dwellings
well two stories in height and
predominantly served by shared service
rows and a series of private drives 14
would be affordable dwellings
in terms of the parking layout
this uh shows where the parking space
would be so most of them would be on on
plot
um parking with some
um visitor parking spaces highlighted
these here are outside the application
site and are within phase two which is
um
set out in your um in the report
just want to sleep so there'll be a
total of 91 parking 91 car parking
spaces 82 allocated and nine visitors
um and cycle storage at the rate of one
per dwelling
So Soft Landscaping
very very much in keeping with the phase
one and two which surrounds it
needs some examples of some house types
again very typical of
um those already approved for phases one
and two so this is three three bedroom
semi another three bedroom semi
um
five bedroom detached
three bedroom detached
another three bedroom detached
one bedroom maisonettes and these these
form part of the affordable housing
offer
and then some photos
um the the site at the moment is is a
construction compound so I couldn't
actually go on the site but this is
looking at the site from the East
um so from from the fanbridge road
Direction and here you've got you can
see some houses that have already been
built on phase one
um in the background as well
so in terms of principle
um obviously feel that it's acceptable
and when the site allocated for a
minimum of a thousand thousand dwellings
and having assessed the details in
relation access layout scale appearance
density Landscaping in the context of
the master plan framework and the design
codes which relate to the site consider
the development would be acceptable in
terms of its courage and appearance and
the quality of life that occupiers of
the pros dwellings then it would also be
acceptable in terms of Highway Safety
access parking flood risk and nature
conservation
um on that point
um as I should have mentioned at the
beginning but it draw members attention
to the members update in within which is
environment agencies latest consultation
response which withdraws their holding
objection to The Proposal
um the parking provision prefers would
wouldn't comply with the general adopty
standards for new residential
development but the doctor standards do
allow for reduced parking within the
garden suburbs where there will be
access to Alternative means of Transport
such as buses Psychopaths and footpaths
as would be the case for this site and
so the occupiers would be able to travel
to services and Facilities within the
garden suburb itself and Beyond
and the other thing to point out or
mention is that there was a previous
application for 33 houses on on this
site and which was refused planning
permission but essentially due to the
portion of smaller dwellings and within
open market housing mix was not
consistent with the housing needs that
had been identified at the time
um and unlike the current application
which does comply with the latest
um
um local housing needs assessment
and the applicant is agreed to make the
necessary Financial contributions toward
Medical Services education
um Rams and provide affordable housing
actually in excess of the minimums
required
and so the recommendations will be
subject to all interested parties first
entering into a section 106 to secure
these Financial contributions and the
affordable housing offered
and therefore um considered that the
development is acceptable and the
reasons refusal for the previous
application have been overcome and the
recommendation is to approve subject to
106 and the conditions detailed in your
agenda thank you thank you Mr Matthews
um we have two public speakers we have
um Mr Colin driver from Morgantown
Council and the applicant Mr Samuel
McCaslin
um Mr driver
um if you could come to the microphone
please
you've been here long enough watching so
the you know that we're going to get a
big two minute clock pop up there
in a second
there we go so when you're ready you
have two minutes thank you good evening
my name is councilor driver I'm a member
of Morgantown Council
um and represent Westward which this
application is part of I and many
residents have grave concerns about the
way in which the Housing Development
around Moulton are being progressed
primarily there is significant concern
about the lack of appropriate
infrastructure to support these
developments
in the report on the examination of the
Malden District's local development plan
to the Secretary of State in 2017 the
expector in stated and I quote the
timely delivery of necessary
infrastructure is an important matter
for any local plan in the case of this
plan it is exceptionally critical issue
the plan focuses housing growth in
Malden haybridge and Burnham and three
have significant all three have
significant infrastructure constraints
the report goes on to say that Highway
and school infrastructure provision is
the most vital issue of housing growth
in Malden and haybridge we are now five
years into the delivery of the local
development plan and considerable
Housing Development has taken place but
with little sign of the necessary
supporting roads to deal with the
increased travel traffic or schools to
address the number of pupils needing
places a result of which is that many
children are being sent to school some
considerable distance from Morton plans
are supposedly in place for further
Primary School places but there are no
clear plans for secondary school places
with a plume school already full the
multi-district council infrastructure
delivery plan identified a range of
needs which included addressing the
acute shortage of medical provision
nothing has happened in this respect the
plan identified funding needs for
infrastructure much of that funding was
to come from a computer a community
infrastructure Levy modern District
Council has failed to achieve this
funding given the lack of infrastructure
for the existing development I see no
grounds on which further development
should take place thank you chair
thank you Council yeah Council driver
that was uh remarkably to a split second
um thank you um if I could call uh for
Mr caselin to come up and thank you
welcome
so when you're ready you have your two
minutes timer visible
thank you chair and good evening
councilors I wasn't planning on taking
up too much time of your time this
evening this has been a fairly
straightforward design process for us
and has received very little uh well
next to no ill sentiment during the
planning process
Taylor wimpy are pleased to bring this
application for your consideration this
evening
as the officer suggested we did have an
application refused here and some of you
may recall that as it did not Accord
with policy that was published
post-submission but we have Revisited
this design after a number of years and
now now in a position that we can fully
address that reason for refusal
the officer report does focus on the
mppf and its presumption in favor of
development given the housing land
supply issues however it is extremely
important to note that this is a scheme
that is also fully compliant with local
policies
as you have heard during the
presentation the scheme according to the
very latest housing needs assessment and
complies with all planning policies
contained in the plan
the designer layout fully Accord with
the design code framework plan and
parameter plans of the outline planning
consent
it also includes affordable housing
Taylor wimpy are pleased with the high
standards we've achieved on this site to
date and this is a fantastic opportunity
to provide much needed new homes in a
sustainable location
as the officer stated there is a wide
range of 106 contributions from The
Wider Lineback Park site and there will
be additional contributions through
these um these units
are therefore respectfully request that
you follow the recommendation in the
report
and approve this application thank you
for your time
thank you Mr Cason thank you very much
indeed
um members we have a recommendation to
approve I read the recommendation it's a
approved subject to the applicant
entrance or legal agreement pursuant to
section 106 of the Town and Country
planning act 1990 Open brackets as
amended to secure the planning
obligations and subject to the
conditions as detailed in section 8. do
I have a second of that recommendation
thank you councilor councilor Helms
seconds the recommendation so I'll open
the device members uh okay councilor
Shaughnessy uh councilor fluka
cancel the stamp
okay but as a ward member whilst we cast
the shaughnessy's award member as well
so
um to to comply we do protocol and
respect I'd like to call Castle
Shaughnessy and after Council
Shaughnessy Council of her members thank
you
thank you chairman
thank you
thank you
um councilor driver made some very good
points on this application
that's all I'm going to say about that I
would look at I want to look at just a
few specifics and ask a few questions if
I may chairman of of the officers
um I'd like
um people
um cancer to look at
5.5.7 and 5.5.8 on page 53
please
and on 5.5.7 it states that the parking
provision would not comply with the
general adopted standards okay that it
states that
um and 5.5.8 it says under provision
of nine spaces
um
which are are lacking um and it says the
reduced standards
um are seem okay in the um in the garden
suburbs
um I'm not um you know I'm not um too
happy about that
um Malden has a huge parking problem
no one here would deny that
how can a deficit of spaces on a new
development be justified
surely this is like you know would be a
domino situation it for the future
um will this lead to problems in the
future that's that's my first question
um shall I go through all my questions
or would you like to answer them one way
I think if you go through all questions
Council Shaughnessy and then we can have
the offices come yeah absolutely uh
thank you chairman
5.6.2 page 54
the last sentence
I'll just wait for
members
find that for a moment it's um talking
about the um Gardens
and this takes us back to the last
application on this
uh back to back distances would
generally comply with the minimum of 25
meters recommended in the Essex design
guide I would like one of the officers
please to explain generally because
we've actually been here before
and 5.6.5 on page 54
um it it references noise Etc in the
above text and I'm just paraphrasing
here future occupiers would be provided
with an adequate quality of life
I'm really sorry I would like that
explained because if I was buying a
property on a new development I would
actually be wanting a good if not better
than good quality of life
and finally
5.9.3 on page 58
I would like the fabric first approach
explained please to members rather than
use Renewables now we all know that
developers really don't like
Renewables at the moment but the fabric
first approach is is new to me if it's
not to other members I apologize and
those are my questions thank you chair
thanks very much councilor Shaughnessy
and Miss Matthews
uh thank you through temen
um
yes so in terms of the parking provision
um
of the officers
and the council has adopted parking
standards and um so those are the ones
that have been used to assess the
proposal
um so I've set out what the what what
the general ones are
um and identified that if their general
ones were being applied then that would
be
um nine in total that they would be
below the minimums but the adoptive
standards do allow for reduced provision
basically in in the garden suburbs
um
you may not necessarily agree with that
that should be the case but that's what
the standards say and that's what the
adopted standards
um the standards have been adopted by
the council say and so on the basis of
that officers have assessed the proposal
and
um felt that
um you know the number of spaces
that are lacking to compile the general
standards are are relatively few few
particularly in the context of 606
houses or there'll be more than that now
would be the lecture 42
um on on the Eastern parcel as a whole
and
um in the adoption center specifically
say that it doesn't say that um in the
garden suburbs you know you can approve
you know below Standard Parking it does
say provided that there are alternatives
for these people to to gain access to
facilities and so in this case they um
there will be a local Center within
walking distance there's going to be a
bus route through phase one
um there's Psychopaths um crisscrossing
um South Morgan Gardens about linking in
with the Psychopaths within Malden
already and so on that basis it would
appear that they there would be
um quite good Alternatives or a good
choice of alternatives to using the
private car
um and therefore
um officer felt in in this case that um
the uh those that exception in the
doctor standards could be applied in
this case
um and therefore to go on to your next
question where was essentially about
whether this was set some sort of
precedent or problem for the future
um that wouldn't that wouldn't be the
case because
um
that any future proposals will be
assessed in in a similar way and if well
I mean if the services were the same
then yes it would mean that the council
would be unreasonable if it then took a
different approach to what has been
suggested here
um but
that's what the adopters tend to say and
that and then and that was they were
they're relatively new in terms of
um parking policy
um and uh yes so that's what's been
applied and in this case office has felt
that
um that the parking proposed would be
would be adequate and to use a word that
you were picked upon on in relation to
another matter
um in terms of back-to-back distances
I've said generally because
um I mean it's been a while since I
measured them all but there might be
some that were like 24 meters back to
back
um them or yeah so but there might not
all be absolutely 25 meters but they
were close very close
um and therefore I didn't want to be
misleading and to say that they are all
25 when why not when when some may not
be quite 25 but they're all very much in
that
um ballpark figure and um no far enough
away for the quality of life to be
acceptable and then you notice about
adequate quality of life
um
it I mean I suppose it's a matter of
opinion where they're all subjective or
whatever there's some you can have a
good quality of life or not but but in
terms of assessing a planning
application
um we're looking to see whether the
proposal is acceptable and it is
acceptable because it would be adequate
quality for Life I.E it wouldn't it
would be um there wouldn't be any reason
to say to refuse up permission on the
basis of the quality of life it would be
proposed and but and also saying
adequate doesn't necessarily mean it
wouldn't be good
um but they're just saying it is
satisfactory it's it um a better word
you think it would be satisfactory and
um having assessed it and taken into
account environmental health advice and
the garden sizes radical the house sizes
were no
above standard minimum standard
um so taking all those factors into
account and the back of that distances
as well
fabric first approach
um go on then because I'd be
um guessing see you chairman um
approaches uh
is an approach that looks to use
materials and building techniques that
reduces the need of energy consumption
so rather so to meet the requirements of
building rigs for energy use they take
that approach rather than having to use
additional equipment such as you know
mechanical plan or Renewables Etc so
it's aimed at reduce its building makes
more than just a wider thing but it's
aimed at reducing the vet where the
energy needs through a design approach
materials Etc rather than through
artificial uh support thank you chair
thank you thank you very much
just going back to the 25 meter issue
um which was very much an issue in the
last application of this
um Miss Matthews are you are you saying
that that that situation has improved
even though it's not perfect has it has
it improved from the previous
application when it was very much an
issue
the only reason the previous application
was refused because it was the housing
mix that they were um
proposing at the time and based on the
housing needs that had been identified
at the time it's the old schmar
um
the current application has has changed
a housing mix and it has been assessed
against our local housing needs
assessment which is more up to date last
year and it complies with with that so
in terms of our current housing needs it
complies and therefore it does overcome
the reason why the only the only reason
why well I actually know them but the
the real reason why it was refused
permission last time the second reason
wasn't more of a technical reason
because the 106 hadn't been signed so it
was protecting the council's position in
terms of
um infrastructure and financial
contributions and that which would have
been required thank you through your
chair um thank you Miss Matthews I I
think um my other Westward member might
um have one or two comebacks on that
thank you chairman very much indeed
yep thank you councilor Stevens yep
thanks very much indeed
um uh councilor heard thank you
um thank you chairman so this
application then uh was originally for
up to a thousand dwellings and this
particular uh piece of land uh was
supposed to have 33 houses on it this
was already refused and now they've come
back and they want 42 houses
which is probably going to equate to
maybe a hundred more people perhaps 130
more cars
which would be a hundred
less doctor's appointments for those
other residents
um
it says the application says that the
density is greater even though the
footprint is smaller 30 DB dph I presume
that's density per hectare is it yeah
okay so it's going it's going from 24 to
30. so how does this affect the quality
of one's adequate life
I don't think it I don't think it does
much for it at all
um again this is saying that this
application is acceptable to those 55
years and over now the likelihood is
that they will probably have a large car
they'll probably have another car maybe
a trailer perhaps a caravan maybe even a
motorhome and yet the spaces that we are
allocating to them is one per house and
yet you've got still some five bedroomed
houses so how does that work out the
money for medical supplies is no good
unless you've got the doctors here and
unless you've got some kind of hospital
if the planning system claims to promote
high quality development through good
inclusive design and layout how is it
that we can refuse 33 houses and then
approve 42.
because I can't understand that
so to me this is over development and
overcrowding this is supposed to be a
garden suburb
but what we've got here
is some kind of inner city development
when you look at the roads
it's cramped it's obviously cramped and
I certainly couldn't support this thank
you thank you counselor
Matthews
thank you chairman
um
in terms of the numbers just to clarify
um
make sure that everyone has understood
um so we've got um s2a which is an
allocated in a local plan
um for this
not like that clear but it's basically
this area here
um excluding the um
um the ER the employment land there so
that was for a minimum of a thousand
houses
so the outline then plan permission that
came in a planning application that came
in
um I thought it was alongside the local
plan allocation was for up to a thousand
houses so that's the uh the mission that
exists but the allocation is for a
minimum of a thousand
um so yes the current application would
add to the Thousand have already been
granted but it would still comply with
the development plan because that that
says a minimum a minimum
um
I think I was something else I had to
say but um I can't remember what it was
but um the so that so that's the
situation but in terms of
um of density you were talking about as
well by two so yes the previous
application was for 33 houses
and current one is 42 which on the face
of it you'd think well that's that's a
lot more dense and a lot more than than
what was refused before and we've
reviewed that so why why why should we
approve
um why should the council approve um 42
but the the housing mixes substantially
changed so there's
um
a lot more not more smaller dwellings so
the footprint is actually less I think
the building footprint
um so that accounts for
um a substantial amount of the the
change and I think the bedroom I think
there's only one extra bedroom if you
counted up all the bedrooms on on the
previous application this one's only one
actually one extra bit so in terms of
impact and obviously on car parking and
things like that it's probably
um comparable with what was
um refused before and it was but it
wasn't refused because of parking or
density or over development
um
in terms of dwellings for hectare 30
dwellings per hectare is still quite low
and no you know in a wider context
um and that and that is the density that
was identified as being suitable for
this part of of the god suburb in terms
because it was all set out within the
parameter plans I mentioned these before
as part of the outline plan permission
so it comprised with that it complies
with the building Heights and the
density
um so you know all these boxes if you
want to call them boxes have have been
have been tipped
um
in terms of medical provision
the outline permission
um as part of the outline for Mission
there was quite a substantial amount of
money to be paid to the NHS to provide
medical services and there will
inevitably be a time lag between the
payment of the money and actual physical
on the ground but that is has been
accounted for as far as developers
concerned as far as the council
concerned obviously when you've got a
third party external body
um involved me also reliant on we are we
are relied on them in actually providing
the services that we've you know secured
the money for
um the current application again
there'll be a further payment for
medical services which the NHS have
advised that's how much they need to
accommodate the medical needs of the
occupiers of the site and particularly
in terms of GPS and the benefits agree
to pay that and that would be secure
through the 106 if if that's
um if that's the resolution that is made
tonight
um
in terms of parking I've talked about
parking already
um
the
all the houses themselves have been
provided with enough well with at least
um what have been provided with either
with one parking space if it's a one
bedroom property or two parking spaces
if it's more than a one bed property
um there are four four bedroom
properties that only have two spaces
um but so they've either all got one or
two
um and that's what the standards say
um is is the minimum required so
um
that will be very difficult to object on
the basis of parking provision if um if
the proposal complies with with the
adopted standards
um in practicing
um in practice that that maybe may be
different on the ground
um but um generally
um that's what
um sorry I lost my train of thought so
but it Compares with adopted policies so
it refusals are on parking would be very
difficult in those circumstances
um you also talk about over development
and overcrowding
um I think I've probably already
answered that in terms of the uh the
densities and comparing what was refused
before with um what's proposed now but
thank you if you've got any questions
then come back counselor it does it does
seem like we're setting for substandards
with smaller Gardens and smaller parking
because who would you like to come back
yeah just on just on 3 1 13 please
chairman and the last paragraph it says
that the the total floor space including
garages has reduced from 39.22 to 39.05
does this mean then that we've got
smaller garages are we building garages
that we can't get cars in these days are
we having parking spaces where you can't
open the doors
are they are they complying with the
larger standard
um three all the garages proposed do
comply with the minimums in the adopted
parking standards that that reference to
including garages was was was included
um just to make sure that
um
yeah so that so that the comparison was
with all the buildings not just the
houses themselves it was without
buildings as well and just to give a
full and complete comparison rather than
a partial partial one that could be
questions as being incomplete
sorry my question was are the parking
places and the garages the larger size
as regards to Essex parking standards
the your chairman they or all the
parking sizes the garages and the
ostrich parking spaces and the Vista
parking spaces they're all this modern
District parking
um standard sizes which are actually
integrated bigger than the Essex County
Council sanitizers but they do comply
the sizes comply
thank you very much uh Council fluka
Kevin I'm I'm I'm slightly confused
because
you know it's very interesting here in
these exchanges but this supplementary
planning documents are very very
important and if you'd read the
supplementary planning document you
would have known the from the point of
view of parking spaces and garages they
are compliant
and what my biggest concern is is Mr
quilch wrote to all members and said you
must read all of the papers relevant to
the planning application before you take
part of vote now clearly uh and I'm sure
Mr quiltsch is listening tonight and if
he's not I'll bring this tape and the
previous one to his attention because
clearly members aren't doing this but
Kevin
um obviously this this is compliant and
and I I hear what members are saying
about a minute and I always remember
years ago where I worked with somebody
and we both aren't exactly the same and
we both bought houses very close to each
other but on opposite sides of the
street and his one was much bigger than
mine and it was cheaper and I asked him
why and at that precise moment the 223
from South End Victoria to Liverpool
Street went past the bottom of his
garden and that's why so and people make
an informed choice but again the officer
has said it does comply I mean what
irritates me enormously is the fact that
these the whole principle of these
developments was Garden suburbs and you
know I I mentioned it last night in a
in a far more robust meeting from what I
remember it
um the councilor Cheshire you know came
had this great idea of bringing forward
Garden suburbs and what they were going
to look like and then we Roll On by I
don't know eight years or something and
we suddenly find that
we've got a minimum of a thousand houses
on this site which is carte blanche
really for the uh for the developer to
build over it and I I sort of remember
this site thank you when it came forward
last time and there was a piece of land
in the middle of it and we just thought
that it was a piece of amenity there and
general immunity land that added to you
know the whole inspiration and concept
of
um the garden suburbs well you know we
can't use that as as a reason to refuse
it if members were minded because we've
got this thousand you know thousand plus
properties so I think we're tied to this
can we just have a look at the the
elevations as my mind drifts towards
policy D1
foreign
these are detached houses
and to determine this is a um
semi-detached house
okay so that's also a semi-attached I'm
sort of detached right so I can see a
detached house so let's so I can see a
detached house and then just go back to
what you said was a semi-detached one
so I can sort of see a half and a half
and a back and a fun a fun Innovation
and a rear Innovation Tim Clyde can I
just mention something at this point as
I struggle to to read
so the area planning committees the
office has always send out the
presentation well they certainly do for
for Southeast
um but we don't seem to get them for
district it's ever so easy just to
follow them here rather than looking at
the screens yeah and we know it works
well at Southeast but I can't really see
how those come together to make a
semi-detached to be fair but they look
you know I can see the back and the
front of the house but they look
completely disproportionate the the size
of the size of the roof in relation to
the fenestrations and the actual height
of of the buildings I mean I personally
uh you know all with all you know the
greatest respect for the design of the
coltford house type
um I don't think it looks very good at
all you know I think it's a bit of an
income Congress design it's you know and
I would have thought unless you've got
any other drawings there it would have
been more than useful to see the two
semi-detached houses bolted together as
a pair rather than what we've got there
so so as I said the design of those in
particular as far as policy D1 concerns
um I think they're questionable actually
but
I'll give way thank you for just a
couple of just before I pass on to the
officer to make any comment I think it's
not impossible to say how people read
and retain information
so people can read the whole document
pack and
you've you can forget especially with
the amount of information and you know
your good self which you would debate
quite a lot about the amount of emails
and correspondence we get about
development so easy to set something
Miss and you've also got the the
officers do send the presentation out
um they often come out quite late close
to the meeting yeah we did yeah you may
yeah no this again that's exactly my
point one can miss something with the
plethora of information I think chairman
I think what you say is a very valid
point and perhaps chairman on behalf of
this committee you'll take that out with
Mr quilts because he was absolutely
admin if you don't read the documents
and the supporting documents because I
asked him you shouldn't be taking part I
think that is a very very big ask
because in theory you should be able to
come into this meeting listen to the
presentation and make an informed
decision on what you've heard and and
you know I don't like this threat of
judicial reviews all the time because
there aren't any well we do a line on
that thanks thanks councilor fluka um
I've got counselor stamp next please
but sorry was there a question in their
counselor
no no I didn't think I thought it was
some very good statements mate thank you
I councilor uh Stamos thank you um
chairman mine aren't really questions
mine's a little bit of disappointment as
per normal
um the I after speaking to
um our affordable housing officer and I
was informed I think three weeks ago
that the the need for our district was
three and four bedroomed for affordable
rather and I thought there was a surplus
of one or two so I'm a little bit
surprised that we've only got three
three three bedroomed houses
um I hope I'm reading the right page
because Council fluke has got me in a
bit of a tis now that I'm actually not
uh on the right page chairman
um we have got obviously the market
dwelling houses you've got six four
bedroomed one five bedrooms 13 three
bedroom and two eight two bedrooms
you've got a one bedroom Mason at six of
I thought we would we'd said that we
don't need one bedroomed houses so I'm a
little bit confused about that it would
be nice if the developer or the office
officers had said could we have the
bigger properties because we all know
the waiting list I don't know if they've
got over a thousand people waiting for
bigger properties in this District I
can't remember off the top of my head I
should have brought the figures because
I've taken them from the officer before
I'll give you a word of warning about
parking offices if you want to listen on
one of our Estates the new Estates where
there isn't enough parking the residents
have taken a problem themselves to rip
up the trees and the shrubs because they
can't park with the number of spaces and
that was with the adequate ones and my
post bag is actually getting filled now
with people sending me pictures of where
they've ripped up the trees and the
actual green infrastructure that should
make the Housing Development better so
that's just a slight word of caution and
the next question it is a question
chairman you'll be pleased to know
rather than move properly and on is that
is the first fabric first to the high
standard of what David Wilson homes is
developing do the officers know because
that's one of the best standards that
the developers can work to
thank you Council stage David Wilson
Home is pretty standard Burnham yeah
thank you um today chairman um I don't
know the answer to that the question
um
um I don't know whether it's how it
compares to Devon Dawson homes standard
um their if that if that is an issue
then
um
no condition could be imposed requiring
further details of of the uh I'll say
more more details of exactly what they
were proposing and the opportunity then
to compare it to the derby people David
Wilson home standard
um but in in terms of the affordable
housing the affordable housing the
affordable rented proposed
fully complies with the local housing
needs assessment requirement in terms of
percentages one two three bedrooms
um there aren't any four bedrooms
um but in terms of one two and three
bedrooms they're fully within the ranges
that are in and have the local housing
needs assessment
um and on I think I did
um mention it earlier but the um they're
they're proposing actually more than the
minimum 30. that they need to provide to
comply with standards and they're also
providing a greater proportion of
affordable rent or the mix
um is
um
sxc is the 75 requirement referred to in
a local housing assessment so they've
actually gone above and beyond what the
local housing needs assessment and it
would require as a minimum
thank you
um Mr Matthews is right because it
actually does stay there on there but
all I've raised is the queries that I've
had with the housing officer housing
officer I've dropped the H to apologize
that we should be looking to to provide
the three under four bedroom and even
five bedroom houses now with bigger
families
um I might be able to assist later if
you interrupt me I forget what I'm going
to say please just because you know what
I'm getting that age I forgetting this I
write it all down
um and I'd like to condition and and I
think it's important it's all right
somebody's saying it's a fabric first
but what standard is it it's like saying
I'm going to build you that house but my
standard is totally different and it
could fall down and we're talking about
you know ecology and everything and
climate so I'd like some sort of
comparison of when developers are not
going to fit retrospect with um solar
panels Etc that we are doing something
to actually combat the climate
difficulties chairman thank you
councilor stem Ms Matthews
I mean as I said earlier a condition
could be could be imposed to require
um at least further details of what they
are proposing
um the the
what they're what they are proposing
um is above building make standards
um but as you say there is with climate
emergency and um and now on other
developments we
um we so the council has imposed
conditions um asking for um further
details of energy saving and milk
cleaner energy production but um so so a
condition could be worded along those
lines to ask for further details with a
view to
um
yeah
beige
if we get further to adopt it to
actually get it so we're actually
working towards we've declared a climate
potentially here
so for that that is
um that is an option if if members wish
to go down that way okay thank you
Council Howell
thank you very much
um it was I was really pleased to see in
5.5.1 they've actually brought up horse
riding and routes and in this area
there's a lot of Livery yards a high
paying rate people
um and wondered where the route was
actually going to be or where you sort
of semi-proposed one for
okay
serious Shaman
um given the location of the site in the
middle of um surrounded by housing all
the way around there'd be no opportunity
to provide
um any vital ways as part of this
development and there there is provision
as part of the existing outline
permission for bridal ways
um but um that's not something that has
um
come up as part of this application and
that was the primarily because of its
location and um yes it's not not a site
that could easily accommodate uh you can
still have an exit for them through
to Farmland at the back
there yeah three German because the red
line is the application site
um so that that would be you know just
permission plan permission for
residential development on three sides
where do you plan to put the cycle route
then
well the cycle routes are um or within
the um the area around so you've got
um Greenways I think this is one of the
Greenways through the site
um and along here as well so they they
run along the site and they're all
provided for and secured through the
outline permission and the other the
previous permissions for the wide site
and so this this site is isn't going to
provide any more cycleways
um but it will be relying on the ones
that are already secured as part of this
of its surroundings
in the same way that it will be relying
on the vehicle access that comes in here
and will come down from from the line
book here so in terms of roads and
cycleways and public open space and
um all the other facilities and the
local Center that I mentioned earlier so
it will be relying on all the ones all
the facilities and services that have
already been secured as part of the
existing outline permission
um as a fan of the things I mentioned
about medical services School places and
everything that that would be extra on
top of what's already been secured
thank you thank you thank you sir
Council Fleming please thank you chair
um my points have largely been made by
others but I will have just have a
little dig about the approved master
plan
um I say approved because I presume it
went through numerous committees
um I just think when we get applications
like this it makes you think what was
the point of doing the approved master
plan if it's just going to be
intensified and then it actually ends up
looking like nothing that the members
wanted in the first place
um you know and I think that's why when
we're local plan making is that you meet
with skepticism from the members for
because of this very thing anyway that's
my point Thank you very very good and
very valid point guys I remember thank
you um Castle Durham please
yeah thank you very much that's a very
very good timing because on the back of
both what councilor femi and councilor
flu cassette
um now I recall 10 or so years ago when
we were shown very elaborate glossy
pamphlets of what a garden suburb will
look like
um and we were taken on a bus I think to
see a garden suburb I can't remember if
it was not the garden village or one of
those that we all went round and had a
look at it and we all thought yeah oh
this is actually really quite nice and
as I said we were given very
um elaborate visuals
uh and this Bears absolutely no relation
to it whatsoever so
to call it a garden suburb is is a
misnomer really but in saying that as
the officers have rightly said it is
policy compliant
um again it's not what we were promised
ahead of the uh the ldp
um as I said and it's not what we were
showing we were going to get 10 years
ago
um but as they say we are where we are
in relation to parking standards whether
you agree with it or not we are not very
far away from the parking standards
being revised to reduce the number of
off-street parking places per house
because of the wish of the government to
make us use sustainable transport and I
do say that I'm afraid with some
knowledge so
um whether you agree with it or not and
I'm reserve my judgment but that that is
just around the corner but uh Yep this
this is policy compliant but it ain't
what we were promised
thank you very much indeed councilor
account suspensely
it's an interesting one for me to follow
on
um with chairman because as a new member
um it actually all feels quite
depressing
I live opposite one Garden suburb where
I've Just Seen loads of oak trees
uprooted and all sorts of other things
and I go down something that looks like
a Mario Kart way every now and again and
just hope nobody throws bananas from the
side
um and um and then I'm I'm sat I'm set
in a committee meeting and joking apart
you know I wonder how many members of
how many residents how many members of
the public realize how difficult this is
when you come into it that you it's
policy compliant and you're you're
obliged to to let these through but
actually it looks nothing like a garden
suburb does it it's it looks like
something out of Coronation Street at
the best
and And
in regards to those very
um disproportionate roofs so I have to
say
um my daughter lives on a Wickford
development where most of those are now
converted to an additional story which
all seems to go through as well that's
just an interesting one to throw in
there but um yeah quite depressing thank
you okay cancer thank you Council
Spencer I think um members of have
raised their points I've got no one else
on my list the members um I think it's
been a very uh informed and interesting
uh debate so we've got a recommendation
which has been seconded
to approve so plus we were looking at an
additional condition with regard to
fabric first
yep so members if we if we add that
condition in there
um
we had a recommendation on the table so
should you want to approve it by sent or
show of hands or
um show our hands is fine okay so those
for the recommendation with the
additional condition to approve okay so
here we go do the best count in head on
one two three four five six
seven eight nine
[Music]
ten eleven twelve do you make that
twelve so it's 12 for the recommendation
those against please
one two three four
four against
okay agree with that those two abstain
one two three okay so that is carried
for approval members thank you very much
we move on to uh agenda item seven any
other items of business that the
chairman and the committee decides are
Urgent and I'm sure you'll be absolutely
thrilled to know we have none so
remember we will close this meeting to
thank a few contributions this evening
I'll draw them into a close at 9 54 pm
thank you